hello and welcome to the new world
review I'm granular perhaps now hello
and welcome to the new it's bad cuz I
know Leo's gonna use it against me I do
you horrible person
hello and welcome to the new world
review I'm grind line waifu and i am
here to warn everyone to keep their
promises you heard me
keep your promises or i'll be under the
bed watching you while you sleep wait no
Hisoka will be under your bed watching
no that's not fair her soap has been
fairly disarming haven't you Sookie
Kilwa will be under your bed watching
you sleep while God sits in a tree
watching you sleep and crap eco gives
you pinkeye hello and welcome to the new
world review where I'm not going to
creep you out at all today we're going
to talk about fluffy bunnies and cute
babies and the purest of the pure
characters in this hellscape we call
hunter hunter sushi because if there's
any character who deserves to be amongst
fluffy bunnies cute babies and maybe
even flying piggies it is my friend your
friend our friend Zushi who is actually
adorable leave him alone don't touch my
baby just like dislike or subscribe all
for him now before we go on this crazy
ride the exits are here here and here
I'm over here here and now I'm here oh
I'm everywhere you cannot escape me and
the spoilers I'm about to lay down right
here episode 32 gosh hisoka's our weirdo
isn't he
but he's my beautiful weirdo so we can
forgive him for everything right so very
much happened in this episode that took
my breath away I don't know where to
start
Castro's downfall his dance of death the
prediction Hisoka being able to
manipulate an arm that had been removed
the trick behind the trick the big
reveal at the end that wasn't a reveal
but was a reveal I simply don't know
y'all there was a lot packed into these
23 minutes of animation and I loved it
all his ogres manipulation of Castro was
artful I'm not the biggest fan
personally of knowing how tricks are
performed so for me his explaining the
physical and men's situation to a pinkie
was okay but not the most entertaining
moment that said having someone explain
a magic trick is one thing having
someone explain a psychological
manipulation and that to me is real
magic the imagery of the cloth to hide
and reveal and assemble is such a
beautiful one and the metaphors that
exist written into his sokka's existence
are phenomenal mostly because in a lot
of tricks that I've seen that involve
cloth the cloth is used to reveal a
result the unique use of it here is to
hide the truth and that is a wonderful
flip on artistic metaphor Hisoka is
upside down as a magician in many waves
which makes sense because if you look at
his hair maybe that's how he sleeps
about one of the great things about the
trick he played on Castro was that we as
an audience could be distracted along
with Castro I sat and computed along
with the audience in the venue I became
part of that audience putting the
equation up on screen gave me a moment
of emotion despite the fact that I'd
seen that equation before and knew what
was happening it was fun it was silly
and it drew me in it showed another side
to Hisoka and you know what the entire
combat sequence showed us another side
to him yes he's been a showman the whole
time and he's been throwing around cards
and engaging in combat the entire time
but what we haven't had so far is a
moment for him to show us that he
actually is a magician and not just
using the persona of one well more on
that later actually he knows how to use
the powers he's acquired he knows how to
entertain even if that entertainment is
the precursor to death and the story he
tells later as he's being sewn back
together finally actually gives us a
little insight into him and his
childhood that said he is the prime
definition of an unreliable narrator but
the idea of a child has sokar wearing a
beanie enjoying candy as he sits on his
bed rather than lurking under one gave
me a pang of sadness only an empath
could feel for a psychopath what can I
say I'm easily manipulated by backstory
it does make me wonder what his history
is how did Hisoka end up here how did he
end up being a person who spends his
time training grooming waiting for
people to develop so he can kill them
he's like a butcher but without the
apron and the cleaver instead of a
cleaver he uses cards instead of an
apron he wears that shirt he likes not
the same at all in fact he's more like a
crazy magician but that much is obvious
so let's move on
who was this mystical person who sewed
him up with linen ins she's a member of
the troupe obviously and she gave his
Sookie the information maybe that Hisoka
passed on to karateka but here's a
question when would his Sokka have seen
karapa cos eyes how would he know karapa
his history did he catch it during gongs
final exam phase when crap occurs eyes
glowed for a moment did he do his
research who's his source and white elk
or a poker where he'd be going
especially if he knew where Gahan was or
could easily track him anyway
his soak is very confusing and one of
the most confusing things about him was
the reveal that he was maybe a member of
the Phantom troop with his elastic love
and flimsy lives they sound really dirty
but we're going to pretend it's not a
thing for now he hides in plain sight
he showed pinky what he was doing he
made it clear
happening and she still didn't pick up
on it that's beautiful storytelling
they're giving to us of information that
she didn't have and she couldn't have I
love that him giving us back story was
called out immediately by her response
of I simply don't care why are you
telling me this it was entirely
pointless information but we still
appreciate it because it's a Hisoka
tidbit and who is she
if the first time we're seeing her rent
nnn nnn nnn in a healing capacity at
least as a healing ability for others a
seamstress healing badass woman with
pink hair who Hisoka seems to like
talking to but who doesn't seem to think
much of him his excitement at watching
her work was nothing compared to his
attempts or at least they look like
attempt to impress her she was not
impressed I like that
oh and before I stop talking to her did
she take a photograph of his injury
before fixing it what was that about
ultimately she can stay can she stay
please she's cool she's also useful so
as much as I feel his Sokka probably
wants to hunt her those ninon stitches
are pretty powerful as is she kilowatt
makes a point of being unable to tell
how his Sokka won but she picked up on
the actions for the most part and that's
worth noting the Phantom troupe if she's
an average member will be a very
powerful and very difficult to defeat
group of people I hope Korra Pecos
training hard oh I wonder if she's the
lay or do equivalent on their team let's
see if anything is made clear in episode
33 episode 33 and it seems Kiowa has
reached his breaking point we don't need
to worry about whether gun is safe we
don't need to worry about whether Zoo
she cute little zoo she is safe and we
don't need to wonder whether sass or
horse at school or sass door you know
his face could melt when he was afraid
for his life because we know that Kiowa
doesn't care and in fact has managed to
prove that if any of us are afraid
enough we don't become the king of the
rat or king of the cat no you're all
wrong he's a rat by the way our faces
just melt clean off because old boy is
Kiowa dangerous when he simply loses
control but in his own controlled way
let's get into things with a little less
terror here our three children began to
train again and they started the episode
assessing with the DVD which was the
cutest ad for new technology I've seen
for a while given the show was made in
the 90s Tara says chicken wing look at
this amazing
way of capturing video-based data in a
rewatchable fashion it was quite cute
and looked so much like product
placement I was surprised when the TV
didn't boot up and show the little
bouncing DVD sign that was the fashion
at the time anyway the three are looking
for his sokka's bubblegum sticky thing
and they can't see it because they're
kids and haven't been trained in it
little sushi can though turns out he's
remarkably powerful for a normal human
person but not when he's walking down
alleyways alone also can I ask why he
was walking down dark alleyways alone
and entirely undefended I know he
probably thinks he lives in a world
where he doesn't need to do that but if
a guy with a vacuum nozzle for a mouth
holding toys a guy in a chair with
combat caterpillar wheels and a creepy
guy who had tried to combat fully molest
me had been around I might not have
decided to go into dangerous places in
broad daylight what was he thinking is
number one
number two have some bloody awareness
child take the long but very much bright
route home you're training with by all
accounts at this point a fowl who's
teaching you to protect yourself and
potentially protect others or at least
someone who's trying to literally teach
you to be aware of things happening
where maybe you wouldn't expect to see
them please sushi
please generalize your behavior it's
okay though because keel was watching
out for you
it's odd actually because this is the
first time Kilwa has been seen to care
actively care about anyone who isn't
gone in the series
yes it's very clear that he cares about
sushi because God cares about sushi but
God also cares about sushi because
kilowatt cares about sushi and both care
about sushi because they want to train
more with chicken wing and if anything
happens to chicken wing he won't be in
any condition to train them it's a whole
sociopathic love cycle I guess it's nice
that keel one gon care about something
and if sushis hanging out with them at
least sushi is safe because they both
reacted in a way that would work out
well for him in fact when they just
about painted that target on little zhu
xi's back at the start of the episode i
almost went to war with the series
myself kills ushi and i'm burning the
whole thing down y'all want dart my eyes
will go as crazy as ki awaaz on a full
moon after a werewolf bite make no
mistake little zoo she is literally the
purest most adorable part of this series
so far and while I understand that that
is a good reason to put a target on him
how very dare you on a lighter note it
was very nice and very confusing to see
Kela in clothing that he's never been
seen in before when did
shopping where did the cap come from is
this weather getting better when did he
start carrying new clothes around with
him will we get to see gone in the
summer fashion of whatever year that is
will they be modeling looks okay back to
the darkness by the end of the episode
it became very clear that something in
Kiawah has broken he's managed to hide
it from chicken wing but maybe not from
gone both kids thought the other had
been threatened and said basically the
same thing about the situation Kiowas
murderous eyes are hyper concerning the
intensity is worrying but it presents us
with a new question of whether he will
be able to control his behavior enough
that he doesn't get gone and himself
into more trouble than not right now
there's a level of control such that he
can hide his intent and abilities from
wing how long will that last as he said
it's really hard not killing it's really
hard for him not to simply act on reflex
this arc has been a fascinating look
into Kiel while learning how to function
in society sure he's learning how to
function in society as a fighter but
that's not being a killer he's learning
how not to outburst and honing those
abilities his father must be so very
proud because frankly killer didn't care
about anything before if you consider
his character at the beginning of the
show he was bored and listless traveling
from phase to phase of the exam looking
for thrills now gone has given him a
basic path and his goal seems to be to
help go on achieve goals and on that
journey it seems that he's found his own
goals that he actually wants to achieve
it's been a great overall character
development for Kiel y thus far even
though there are very deep concerns
about how enduring his behavior will be
between the two episodes there has been
a great deal of fascinating new
information and I'm loving the term this
arc is taken I can't wait to see some
more but now is not the time for that so
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
check out the patreon and check out this
video here in that video there and maybe
buy a beanie and maybe give me your soul
on the discord server and tell Liam to
stop eating my ice cream have a great
week everyone good bye